look
you know i got a call from one of my
mentors
advisors very successful president of a
multi-hundred billion dollar company
uh uh and he's in his 70s and we had a
great conversation to get he says look
in life
here's how it works he says you're going
to have battles
there's going to be little fights that
happens all the time with you and
somebody with you and family with you
and a friend with you and all that stuff
he says the goal is to try to get the
battles to be done somebody wins you
move on everybody goes about their
business right
he says then there's wars when there is
a war
you have to know that every country has
to defend themselves okay
i have to defend me you have to defend
you and you know there's going to be
some
casualties at the end of the war no
matter what if you go to war there's
casualties
he said then there's nuclear wars when
it's nuclear wars
it lasts a long time and the amount of
blood in your hands gonna be a lot
last 12 months politically was a nuclear
war and
the way they went after trump it doesn't
end there it's not like there's no
residual effects to it there's
still going on right now it's nothing
it's nothing the residual effects of the
last 12 months is not a one-year
residual effect
the residual effects of the last 12
months is a 10 20 year residual effects
are you kidding me
let me put it to you this way the
residual effects of the last 12 months
could be
25 year effects of a barren trump type
of residual effect
like you have to know you offended my
dad
so so this what they did last year may
be like hey it's called
you know oh yeah so you did that to
trump we're going to do this to knew
some we're going to do this
so so they started they started a
nuclear
war and it's not you took trump off
watch how long it takes until the next
damn president
just it's just what are you going to say
no so they started
a nuclear war and now they're impeaching
who in the world cares about a former
president being
impeached like let me say this one word
like okay
it's like saying i'm gonna fire an old
employee that i've already let go of
what are you talking about so you
understand like you came you served your
six months you're 12 months
a year later i want to change it from
that you just did your time and your
contract you wrapped it up no no i want
to change it to i
fired you what are you talking about
no one in the world cares about a former
president being impeached move on
he's a former one-term president what's
worse than being a one-term president
how many one-term presidents do we have
been impeached
you know what it is to be a one-term
prayer what's worse than a one-term
president
jimmy carter one term senior one term
there is nothing worse than being a
one-term president nothing for a
president are you saying they should not
even prove no
any of the illegals are already bad
enough but
since they're doing it they just have to
be prepared
for the nuclear war in the world of
politics
are you saying that they should i'm not
i'm not saying that this is we're this
is conversation right here
should they not pursue what's good
because they just started this you know
second impeachment trial
everything that's going on should they
or should they not yeah it's not shady
or should they not okay
a long time ago i had to you know in my
20s
it was always about no but they're wrong
no but they're wrong no but they're
wrong
like listen after plenty of books to
read and
mentors counsel all this stuff dude you
don't need to win everything
certain things you just you just gotta
let go of it this is not worth it this
is embarrassing why do you think they're
going after himself
it's i think it's a little too much i
think it's like proven a point he's the
first to be impeached twice do you think
there's a
any part of it where they're trying to
make sure that he's barred from from
running
i think that's the big one trying to put
the nail in the coffin 100
that's it but i tell you one i talked to
oliver north uh yesterday or two days
ago
yesterday i talked to oliver north and i
said who's your number one candidate for
he said mike pence i said okay i said
do you think trump should run in 2024.
he said no absolutely not he says
they're going to destroy his businesses
they're going to go after him he says
what he needs to be focused on right now
is to take care of his family
because it's going to be pretty ugly
this is oliver you'll see i'm prepping
obviously i'm uh you know yeah and by
the way i'm familiar with oliver north
yeah um
iran contract yeah he talks about it
he's a former general what was
lieutenant colonel
famous in the early eighties this when
was the iran continent 8184 like that
reagan second he was famous for a big
trial on capitol hill
you know for those of you who are not
familiar got arrested for those you know
five people were not arrested guilty
okay so he was one of them poindexter i
think was another one
uh of five cia agents and a couple other
names
this is like the equivalent i'm i'm not
exact but like this is a watergate-ish
benghazi type in the news
type of it was like holy moly oliver
north on trial yeah so it was a 30
million dollar
money that they got to work with i think
a country that they were protecting the
country
you know nicaragua but it's a small
region of it and they took out of that
again i you can go verify this 18
million
to buy weapons for iran and give weapons
to so it was a very
uh interesting thing that took place
this is also on the tail end of the cold
wars you have the whole russia
or communism versus capitalism and and
the ideolo
ideological fight as well yeah yeah so
so the whole challenge is you know
oliver north said i don't think he needs
to run i think he needs to take care of
his family but
the point i'm trying to make here was
newsome i'm not surprised
you you caused a nuclear war so when you
cause a nuclear war there's going to be
a few what
casualties newsom is going to be one of
them period newsom is a casualty
because of the nuclear war and i think
they knew they're going to have
casualties
i think they knew they were going to
have casualties this if it happens
you potentially eliminated one of your
future presidents so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye